觉得你真的是榜样来的，
是我们所有的遇到这种事情的女性当中，
你做的非常对，
是榜样来的。
后续的事情我是这样理解的啊，
不管你怎么选择，
你选择拿钱谅解也好，
你选择不拿钱要求追她的更重的刑事责任也好，
都是你的选择，
不要被任何人道德绑架，
不要被任何人把你嫁到一个什么样的一个位置去，
是这样子的，
我遭遇了这场骚扰，
婚姻报警了，
我不知道现在该怎么办了，
没有联系，
也不知道是什么情况，
现在报钩的时候你手上有哪些证据呢？
我的贴身衣物，
我当时擦拭身体的纸巾，
还有就是擦就他的里肯定会有人下一些唾液什么的，
当时那个貌似叔叔都有采集了生物，
真是，
那你很勇敢，
姑娘，
你做的很棒，
而且很专业，
既然已经报钩了，
那我们就等待他现在是被拘了呢还是怎么的呢？
不知道，
我现在对这些一点不知道，
所以我心里有点慌，
你可以去派出所去问嘛，
现在是一个什么情况，
对方有没有被拘啊，
我也是在北京，
出事地点是在朝阳，
我是在门头沟这边报，
嗯，
他们说到时候会一觉过去再联系，
我当时也没有留下您什么什么景的联系方式是吗？
有那留下了，
那就因问他，
因为出事点不是在门头沟这边，
是在朝阳那边，
所以他说到时候给朝阳那边去定义，
之前这个案子就是定性的话，
还不知道是某伟戏还是。
鸿沟，
但是它是没有进行到最后一步的，
大概是一个小时左右，
这期间我没有呼救，
因为当时非肠害怕，
我全身都湿透了，
就是反抗嘛，
也不是说非常激烈，
我没有伤，
我那离散的外伤，
所是我一直都有说不同意嘛，
她是在办公室，
是不是因为我是做家政阿姨的，
是在雇主家里边，
你是从雇主家里面出来就爆钩了是吗？
我是第二天下午出来，
出来之后我就报勾了，
我回到我住的地方，
我觉得我安全了，
我就报钩了，
那你做的很棒，
第一你没有像那些其他的影视作品那样说先洗澡先干嘛干嘛，
证据都冲没了再去报的，
你是留了这些唾页，
留了这些衣服上的这些证据去报的，
你做的很棒了，
那现在我们就等待派出所的联络，
就是你看我也没有工作，
我自己也是一个单亲妈妈，
经天说还是比较有压力，
后续我可能没有能力去请律师，
我是可以申请法律援助嘛，
申请法律援助得可能要开出很多证明，
去你的户籍所在地要开出证明，
证明你的经济状况要符合那个条件才可以申请法律援助，
这样子的呀，
对，
一会儿我的管理员帮我关注一下你，
我可以把这300块钱退给你，
然后退给你的目的是什么？
不是有理由的，
是因为我本人啊，
我不是一个刑事这方面的专业的律师，
所以我能够给到你的建议和给到你的技术支持是非常有限的，
你拿着这300块钱，
你可以在网上。
找曾经做过刑事，
尤其是做过强案，
做过违亵案的律师去问，
比如说你问问那个郭庆子律师，
或者是兰江律师，
或者是罗欢平律师，
他们可能能给你更多的技术支持，
是这个情况，
丁汝兰律师呢？
丁汝兰律师好像她老公我不知道是不是做过刑事这方面的也可以去问，
因为这300块钱的话，
最起码你能问好多个律师了，
都假设说你经济条件不允许你在线下找一个律师的话，
那么我们就花这300块钱在线上多找几个律师去问，
我想知道是我希望准备一些什么，
真的，
其实一提到这个事情，
我还是会像当时那个状态一样，
非常紧张，
全身冒冷汗。
实话说啊，
如果说有他的企业，
有他的经验，
有这些东西的话，
大概率下是有可能进行一种协商赔偿，
对方是没有任何人联系我，
家政公司老师到时候一直来问我，
但是我也问过对方，
对方说我就不要跟他们透露任何细节，
我就跟他们说，
我说我不方便说，
那就对了，
那就可以啊，
我觉得你真的是榜样来的，
是我们所有的遇到这种事情的女性当中，
你做的非常对，
是榜样来的，
后续的事情我是这样理解的啊，
不管你怎么选择，
你选择拿钱谅解也好，
你选择不拿钱要求追他的更重的刑事责任也好，
都是你的选择，
不要被任何人道德绑架，
不要被任何人把你嫁到一个什么样的一个位置去，
都是你的选择，
都OK，
既。
在的话，
我也问过警察商了，
我说你们这个电信是强制诬陷还是说会谁，
他们说这个得看朝阳那边怎么定信这个案子他就是没有完全进入村体，
但是你问律师的时候的话，
可能你有过这方面经验的律师会去问你当时是一种什么心理，
为什么当时没有叫，
为什么当时没有反抗，
为什么是第二天了之后才去报勾，
你要把你真实的那心理状况跟这些网上的这些做过这方面案子的律师去沟通，
你刚刚问我的这些，
当时墨子叔叔做笔录的时候都有问过我，
因为你家政公司的人也有可能介入进来，
但是我跟这个家政公司并不熟，
我是第一次接他们的单，
而且我是上户的第二天，
因为第一天晚上是之前那个阿姨还在，
第二天晚上就我单独跟雇主，
因为当时接的这个单就是照顾一个老总，
我有问过家政公司的派单老师，
我说这是个什么单，
她跟我讲这是正经的单，
我才接的，
因为我想到照回一个男士，
其实我女性不太方便嘛，
他指定要我们那个地区的人，
你知道吗？
尽量不要跟这个雇主再有任何私下的语言的聊天记录，
就算这个雇主提出来要花多少钱解决这个事情的话，
你暂时都不要有任何的回复，
就算是说要赔偿的话，
一定是在派出所有帽子叔叔的主持之下去进行这样一个协商，
私底下不要协商会不会花钱换算用。
用权力去把这个事情和谐交通说变成比较小的事情，
这个事情尤其是在北京这样的地界，
他未必能有这么的手眼通天，
当时他在这个事情之前，
他也跟我说他有一些什么关系，
什么呢？
其实我也有关心他会报复或怎么样，
你当时有录音吗？
就是他的语言上的这些，
接下来啊，
任何人给你打电话，
只要你怀疑这通电话有可能是男方主动打过来的或者是干嘛的，
你一定要记住录音，
全程录音，
任何情况下，
这个男方要找你协商也好，
找你赔偿也好，
要找你干嘛也好，
一定记住录音，
所有的证据都要留下来啊，
好，
就这样啊，
拜拜管理员帮我联系一下这个姐妹啊，
她真的很勇敢了，
现实生活中的这种，
作为家政人员去到雇主家里面啊，
遭遇伤害，
或者遭遇这种情况，
其实在家政这个行业里面也这种情况，
一张一大把，
我只能这么说，
他们拿准了你没有证据意识，
你没有法律观念，
你没有资源，
拿准了你可能是个单亲妈妈，
拿准了你谁要是说不是逼不得已，
谁愿意给人当家政呢？
这纯属欺负人，
我都跟姐妹们说过，
我平等的瞧不起一切仗势欺人的人，
无论她社会地位有多高，
成就有。
多高，
无论他多么在专业上多么受到什么敬仰什么的，
我仗势欺人的人，
我真的是平等的瞧不起一切。
这样的人记得点赞关注哦。